aujourd'hui en a 4 encore en arrêt c'est
un casse tête permanent
tous les matins ce directeur et son
adjointe remonte à bout de bras un
planning qui s'écroule l'été sera
difficile et la canicule n'arrange rien
on est dans un cercle vicieux
effectivement où on rappelle les gens
sur leur jour de congé
donc à un moment donné les gens sont
fatigués donc à nouveau on a des arrêts
maladie
au jour d'aujourd'hui on est dans
quelque chose qui devient ingérable
certains jours on est en mode dégradé on
ferme la blanchisserie donc voilà le
linge les petites tâches ménagères
on les laisse de côté pour privilégier
les résidents et le bien-être de nos
résidents récemment huit directeurs
d'ehpad du département du jura ont pris
la parole dans la presse ils dénoncent
le manque chronique dead soignant une
parole inédite dans un milieu plutôt
discret dans une lettre commune
il tire la sonnette d'alarmé le métier
d'aide-soignant n'attire plus c'est
forcément l'état lui-même qui doit
réagir par rapport à ça et on préconise
en effet de revaloriser déjà le métier
de soignant des dents une aide soignante
va démarrer au smic et au bout de 20 30
ans sera à peu près à 1400 1500 euros
grand maximum c'est quand même pas un
salaire très attirant seule solution
pour ces directeurs faire travailler des
personnes non diplômées jusqu'à 30% des
effectifs
désormais les agences d'intérim n'ont
pas de personnel vous passez des offres
d'emploi vous n'avez pas de réponse
ou quand vous avez des réponses et pas
forcément que les diplômes adapté en 27
ans de carrière c'est la première fois
où j'avoue n'a pas de solution faute de
personnel cet été ce directeur a dû
fermer l'accueil de jour une trentaine
de personnes âgées et leurs familles
devront s'en passer